if anyone wants a recommendation from me
in terms of science fiction reading then
I've got to say pretty much anything by
Ted Chang now teaching became sort of
well-known recently because one of his
stories was adapted to become the
science fiction film arrival I thought
that was a really awesome movie and the
story from which it was adapted is also
amazing that story is one of the many in
this book that I have it's a collection
of Ted Chang short stories and I'm going
to talk about from this book my favorite
three and why I love them first of all
the reason that I love Ted stories is
that whilst they all involve some sort
of science fiction futuristic thinking
or even just mathematical ideas
something sort of science II that's not
what the stories are about that just
provides the context and the flow of the
story the stories are all about
something much more down-to-earth about
human emotions human struggles and what
it's like to be people facing these
bigger questions that are presented to
us from science and from advances and
technology and and things like that
the first story I'm going to mention is
called division by zero now this story
is presented almost like a mathematical
proof in itself it deals with the nature
of mathematics and the nature of
certainty in essence without trying to
give spoilers really and but to tell you
what it's about the main character is a
mathematician and she's a really amazing
mathematician that she proves something
she proves that one equals two
and this is something in mathematics
that actually has a history of people
trying to prove this or people try to
think can you prove this because really
whether you can or not is the foundation
of of how we use mathematics so there's
a quote in the story and the quote is
from David Hilbert the mathematician
says if mathematical thinking is
defective where are we to find truth and
certitude and that's kind of the essence
of this story if you've managed to prove
something that shakes the foundation and
the underpinning of what you would
consider truthin and what we base our
mathematics on how can you find any sort
of meaning in life after that the main
character tackles with that question she
has nightmares where she can't
distinguish between life and death
because if she can't distinguish between
the numbers 1 & 2 how can how could she
think about anything in the same way
anymore that's the sitting of the story
but the story is really not about maths
as much as I say that it's about human
empathy and love in this context of
mathematical truth there's one more
thing I want to mention about this story
and it's following a discussion and the
author's notes at the end about a very
beautiful mathematical equation he says
a proof that mathematics is inconsistent
and that all its wondrous beauty was
just an illusion would it seems to me be
one of the worst things you could ever
learn maybe I sort of agree with that
and that's why I like the story so much
the second story that I want to mention
is a very short one but I thought it was
really thoughtful it's called the
evolution of human science and it was
originally published in the scientific
journal Nature and it's kind of funny
that it was because it ties with the
idea of well what is the future of
journals in a world where humans are no
longer at the forefront of science and
instead say AI or something else is I'll
read one quote to you that is from the
first paragraph of the story what is the
role of human scientists in an age when
the frontiers of scientific inquiry have
moved beyond the comprehension of humans
so I really liked that in the story
these meta humans communicate their
research through like digital neural
transfers so essentially they just
communicate with each other humans are
left out of the loop but the scientific
journals still exist for humans to try
and decipher what's actually going on in
science they no longer make
contributions it's more of a translation
exercise of scenes the story asks the
main question what would our role be
what would the role of a human scientist
be but it's actually rather optimistic
it doesn't say that there would be no
need for human scientists it makes a
valid argument that you would still need
human scientists if you're still going
to have humans because you need someone
doing some sort of science that is
actually representative of of a group of
people that aren't being represented
otherwise it almost seems like the
author is tackling the fundamental idea
of diversity and science and why you
need unique voices because otherwise a
certain group of people and their needs
or probably get left behind the last
story I'm going to mention to you is the
namesake of this book and that's the one
that became the movie arrival it's
called the story of your life and
essentially if you haven't seen the
movie or read the story we're dealing
with aliens that visit earth and we're
trying to communicate with them but we
learn things from the way that they
communicate
and sort of the ideas that they consider
important enough to communicate we learn
things about linguistics about what's
important to us and what might be
universally important I really like this
story because there's some physics in it
and there's some really cute diagrams in
here too because there is a whole
section this didn't really make it into
the film but there's a whole section in
the book about Fermat's principle of
least time and how that works at a
air-water interface so I'll try and show
you some of the diagrams but we
essentially see focus we essentially
have air and water and we've got light
going between them and this is
refraction so when light gets to say
water it bends now the reason it bends
is because it wants to travel that total
distance from A to B in the least time
possible but the least time possible you
might think well wouldn't that just be a
straight line and that's the dotted line
in this picture but that's not the
fastest path because in fact if you were
to take that dotted line you would be
traveling for a longer time through the
water but water slows down the movement
of the light so actually you want to get
to a happy medium where you're traveling
a certain distance and the waters
Hendersons and air and the speeds there
will come out to give you the shortest
path it's a principle that applies
across a lot of areas of physics
it's a variational principle and I think
it's discussed quite well in the book
from our classical perspective this idea
has some quantum mechanics underpinnings
and they're not discussed here but um
from a classical point of view you can
almost look at it and this is what the
author has done is looked at
this principle and it almost seems like
light can see the future it can see its
path before it embarks on that path and
and that's really the essence of the
story here it's away from the physics
and away from the aliens and all this
sci-fi sounding stuff this is a story
about someone that knows their fate and
has to learn to accept it it's I found a
really sad story like I cried in the
movie adaptation of this I don't know I
just really liked it it's it's about
sort of having your future laid out in
front of you and instead of trying to
change the bad things accepting at all
as the journey that you're going to take
if you've read any of Ted Chang stories
please let me know which ones you liked
and since I've finished this book I'm on
the lookout for some more short stories
hopefully with a science fiction sort of
being so I'd love to hear some your
recommendations too